a red iPhone what are you signing up to
big news yeah the bad iPhone has
actually been rumored for quite a while
and I don't know if anybody really
thought it was ever actually going to
happen because that's what happens
rumors but it's here yesterday it was
announced at the red iPhone is a thing
and it's going on sale this Friday at
8:01 a.m. I've been getting so many
messages and tweets and texts I woke up
yesterday morning the day of the
announcement and it was just stream
shots of the Apple website hey did you
see this are you going to get one what
are you saying I absolutely love the red
product line because not only do they
look really freaking cool but it's also
for a really good cause so props to
Apple for doing this they've been doing
it for quite a while and this iPhone
actually looks a lot like the red iPod
that they had a while back here's the
iPod Nano looks pretty good and you know
they're going for that some of the team
a lot of the criticism was that it
didn't have a black front I'm going to
be completely honest with you I am a
huge fan of the black front phone and
that's one of my biggest complaints on
the colored phones is the white around
the edges I like having a completely
flushed phone seamless and beautiful
which is why I decided to go with the
jet black phone I mean it's no more
looks so good it's moving all black
front but it makes sense because it's
kind of in their product line if this is
how they have been doing things for
quite a while I hope this is a joke that
didn't actually ever happen right
especially one-of-a-kind collector's
piece thank God I'm sure you guys are
all subscribed to MTA PhD because he
actually had a red iPhone in his hands
is an official unboxing already and it
looks really really good you guys want
to check that out of the link in the
description and my question to you guys
is do I get it I mean it looks really
really good thing is most people
probably who are going to get a 7 plus
have probably already got their 7 plus
so this is something I feel like if
people have held out for the newer phone
they aren't quite ready to upgrade to
the next version that will be coming out
after this and I feel like that's
probably the market statistics for or
people who just really really like red
but this is the thing - I can't not have
a case on my phone because I am
completely reckless as you guys
have seen in the past so really unless
you have a red piece on no one's even
going to know that you have a red phone
because the front of it it's a little
silver button they do not I know on the
gold phone because I have that one for
quite a while the ring around the touch
ID button it matched the phone man that
would have been so cool and if you don't
want to buy an entirely new phone you
can just get a red case and still have
that same field they've open up a smart
battery case for you guys from 7 so if
you do have one of these smaller phones
there you go that's for you I'm
surprised they haven't made the larger
version of this got the red apple watch
sportsman that looks so good I think
that would look so good on not wearing
my watch it's charging currently that
would so live with the ceramic base up
we'll just skip over the beats because
those look not like something I'm into
any case you don't want to buy an
entirely new phone you can get an aqua
lime shuffle I didn't even know to be
were still selling those I love the iPod
Nano I thought it was just so cool and
you got some red gazing through your
iPad let's take a peek at the models and
pricing and see how much these things
are going to run up so if you buy it
without a carrier you've got a 128 and
256 76 is nine hundred and sixty nine
dollars and I would definitely recommend
getting Apple care because my face were
made and I did not get it I've shattered
my phone away too much so an iPhone 7
without a carrier 849 that's not even
that much less than the seven plus so
that's silly like I'm not going to lie
like it looks good so Apple press
release here we've got the iPhone 7s of
them plus and then they also announced a
new nine point seven inch iPad this is
interesting apples quiet iPad launch
proves no one cares about tablet yeah
that franchise has gone from headlining
marquee Apple of them to showing up an
applied announcement via press release
which here's the problem I mean I feel
like there are so many tablet options
now that it's really hard to type in
that market and be sort of something
that is stand out I've had definitely
started it all it really pushed that
tablet market into what it is today
and
now it's time for something else the
iPhone 7 plus is so huge that most
people that probably would be using an
iPad and have an iPhone 7 plus there
really is no point in having the iPad as
well and now was it intended switch just
another thing to carry I had a scratch
oh no the last time an iPad it felt
truly special was back in 2011 when
Steve Jobs came back for medical leads
to unveil the iPad 2 and again before
competitors closed market who is a
cheaper tablet and with things like the
Microsoft Surface I mean you're getting
an entire computer and also a tablet all
sort of in one and I still feel like the
iPad does not have a full working
operating system it still is iOS that's
a problem I'm not going to be able to
make that I've had Perl into a full
working computer because it's me not
even though Apple is pushing that agenda
the role people who are doing normal
everyday things yeah you can completely
get away with it other people who aren't
doing things like that like the
professional market line it's not going
to work this is pretty interesting to
apple also announced a clip video app
I'm excited to see how this goes Apple
has tried to become social in the past
but I think like iTunes Connect or
something you guys remember that
hey I'm editing this video right now
when I remembered what it was called it
was I can ping didn't even remember that
I can I was like 2012 I want to say to
have 11 from 12
I remember adding friends and I was so
excited for like two days and then just
didn't ever touch it again so you can't
really technically compare it to
snapchat or Instagram it's basically its
own standalone app so it's kind of like
those things that you see on Facebook
like the flat down cooking videos people
always adding cool subtitles and kind of
making it sort of an interactive thing
because a lot of those videos they don't
usually have audio at first you have to
turn those on which is why subtitles and
things like that are very very important
supposedly this will add live titling we
all know how the YouTube subtitles works
not only that accurate so I'm hoping
that this is definitely a little bit
better than that
catch your a moment hold to record say
it and see it live title will see as we
create animated captions just by talking
issues
man hope it works hope it works pick a
filter drop it in emoji I want to see
more coming soon but when we need to
know when so here we go okay you're
making a little clip we're here moving
day
it looks pretty cool and I have high
hopes because honestly you know Apple
when they do things right they do things
right it's crazy how things that when I
first started making videos and editing
in graphic design an extremely long time
ago I was probably in like sixth grade
when I started trying to figure out how
to use macromedia fireworks
anybody remember oh my goodness you know
I only had 30 day free trial
I'd have to format my computer every 30
days because I didn't know how to you
know hack it so that I could I was I was
at that time I was like 10 it fit things
were not like they are now at all so I
just thought that's what I had to do and
I didn't have a job I was a child and my
mom was not going to be paying thousands
and thousands of dollars for software
because that's just crazy it was hard
enough to convince her that for my
birthday I wanted RAM obviously things
have changed significantly and I love
right now right now is such an
incredible time for technology I know a
lot of you guys are probably the age
that I was when I probably first was
getting into coding I was in sixth grade
I don't know how old you are in sixth
grade maybe like 11 or 12 and the first
time that I figured out how a website
was made I was at nintendo.com
I went to view source and it my eyes on
wondermint when this page of text was
just before me so I would take some of
that text from other websites and I
would take it into one of those free web
site hosting things where you could sort
of just drop in HTML and then see what
it looks like there's ads everywhere so
I was like copying and pasting code from
other websites just trying to see how it
worked and now you don't have to really
do any of that which is kind of crazy
but I'm super excited for you guys and
the future and everything awesome that
you guys are going to get to experience
because
it's going to be so cool I guess to burn
this whole video to a close of course I
always ramble when I do these types of
videos let's see what was I even talking
about the red iPhone I'm also searching
for Zelda recipes because I'm going to
be spoiler hello making some Zelda food
if you guys have been playing Zelda let
me know if there's any recipes that you
would like me to make keep it simple I'm
probably thinking more along the lines
of like a meat and mushroom skewers so I
tracked side tracks so yeah iPhone 7
iPhone 7 plus in red I have a video
coming out next week with my new friend
Sarah DG she's so cool and we did sort
of an iPhone 8 wish list so that will be
out next week and this was all before
this whole red iPhone kind of came out
so we definitely don't make any mention
to that for good reason because it
didn't happen yet Apple park opens to
employees in April let me check this out
am I an employee no will I ever be no
can I get a visitation can I have
visitation right probably not please and
just to reiterate I don't work for them
they've never paid me they've never told
me to say anything that I'm saying I am
just a true fan much love now Menezes
video second supply soda by the
centerpiece of the party is the question
Joey please join all right oh you click
here oh yes which